the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I'm Haynes Miller I'm substituting for
David jerison today so you have a
substitute teacher today so I haven't
been here in this class with you so I'm
not completely sure where you where you
are I think you've just been talking
about differentiation and you've got
some examples of differentiation like
these basic examples the derivative of X
to the N is n X to the N minus 1 and I
think maybe you spend some time
computing the derivative of the sine
function as well recently and I think
you have some rules for for extending
these calculations as well for instance
I think you know that if you
differentiate a constant times the
function what do you get
the constant comes outside like this or
I could write C u Prime and see u Prime
that's this rule multiplying by a
constant and I think you also know about
differentiating a sum or I could write
this as u plus V prime is U prime plus V
Prime so I'm going to be using those but
I'm today I'll talk about a collection
of other rules about how to deal with a
product of functions a quotient of
functions and best of all composition of
functions and then at the end I'll have
something to say about higher
derivatives so that's the story for
today that's the program so let's begin
by talking about the product rule so the
product rule tells you how to
differentiate a product two functions
and I'll just give you the rule first of
all the point the rule is it's U prime V
Plus u B Prime a little bit funny
differentiating a product gives you a
sum but let's see how that works out in
a particular example for example suppose
that I wanted to differentiate the
product well the product of these two
basic examples that we just talked about
I'm going to use the same variable in
both cases instead of different ones
like I did here so the derivative of X
to the N times sine of X so this is a
new thing couldn't do this without using
the product rule
so the first function is X to the N and
the second one is sine of X and we're
going to apply this rule so you as X to
the N you prime is according to the rule
in X to the N minus 1
and then I take V and write it down the
way it is sine of X and then I do it the
other way I take u the way it is that's
X to the N and multiply it by the
derivative of V V Prime we just saw V
prime is cosine of X so that's it
obviously you can differentiate longer
products products if more things by
doing it one at a time let's see why
this is true I want to try to show you
why the product rule holds so I think
there's you have a standard way of
trying to understand this and it
involves looking at the change in the
function that you're interested in
differentiating so I should look at how
much the product UV changes when X
changes a little bit well so how do we
compute the change well I write down the
value of the function at some new value
of X X plus Delta X well I better write
down the whole new value of the function
and the function is U times V so the
whole new value looks like this it's U
of X plus Delta X times V of X plus
Delta X that's the new value but what's
the change in the product well I'd
better subtract off what the old value
was which is U of x times V of X ok now
according to the rule we're trying to
prove I have to get u prime involved so
I want to involve the change in U alone
by itself let's just write try that I
see part of the formula for the change
in U right there let's see if we can get
the rest of it in place so the change in
X is U of X plus Delta X minus U of X
all right that's the change in X
it occurs this party that occurs up here
multiplied by V of X plus Delta X so
let's put that into now this equality
sign isn't very good right now I've got
this product here so far but I've
introduced something I don't like I've
introduced you times V of X plus Delta X
right - that so the next thing I'm going
to do is get is correct that little
defect by adding in U of x times V of X
plus Delta X ok now I've canceled off
what was wrong with this line but I'm
still not quite there because I haven't
put this in yet so I better subtract off
U of X u times V and then I'll be home
but I don't I'm going to do that in a
clever way because I noticed that I
already have au here so I'm going to
take this factor of U and make it the
same as this factor and so I get U of x
times this minus U of x times that
that's the same thing as u times the
difference so that was a little bit
strange but when you stand back and look
at it you can see multiply it out the
middle terms cancel you get the right
answer well I like that because it's
involved the change in U and the change
in V so this is equal to Delta u times V
of X plus Delta X minus U of x times the
change in V well I'm almost there the
next step in computing the derivative
take the difference quotient divide this
by divide this by Delta X so Delta u V
divided by Delta X is well I'll say
Delta u divided by Delta X times V of X
plus Delta X my
if I made a mistake here this plus
magically became a minus on the way down
here so I better fix that plus u times
Delta V over Delta x su is this u over
here so I've just divided this formula
by Delta X and now I can take the limit
as X goes to zero so this is Delta X
goes to zero this becomes the definition
of the derivative and on this side I get
the UD x times now what happens to this
quantity when Delta X goes to zero so
I'm getting closer and closer so X is so
this quantity is getting closer and
closer to X so what happens to the value
of V it becomes equal to X of V that
uses continuity of V so the X plus Delta
X goes to a of X by continuity so this
gives me times V and then I have u times
and Delta V Delta X gives me DV DX and
that's the formula that's the formula as
I wrote it down at the beginning over
here the derivative of a product is
given by this sum yep
from from here to here well so maybe
it's easiest to work backwards and
verify that what I wrote down is correct
here so if you look there's a u times V
of X plus Delta X there and there's also
one here and they occur with opposite
signs so they cancel and what's left is
U of X plus Delta x times V of X plus
Delta X minus u times V and that's just
what I started with
you cancel right I cancelled out this
term in this term and what's left is the
ends
any other questions though yes
where
well I took I just calculated what Delta
UV is and now I'm going to divide that
by Delta X on my way to computing the
derivative and so I copied down the
right hand side and divided by Delta X I
just decided to divide the U by the
Delta u by Delta X and the Delta V by
Delta X good anything else so alright so
we have the product rule here the rule
for differentiating a product of two
functions this is making us stronger
there are many more functions you can
find derivatives up now how about
quotients let's find how to
differentiate the quotient of two
functions
well again I'll write down what the
answer is and then we'll try to verify
it so there's a quotient let me write
this down there's a quotient of two
functions and here's the rule for it so
I always have to think about this and
hope that I get it right
you prime the minus UV prime divided by
V squared this may be the craziest rule
you'll see in this course but there it
is and I'll try to show you why it's
true and see an example yeah there was a
hand sorry
what letters look the same U and V look
the same I'll try to make them look more
different
these have points on the bottom the use
have little round things on the bottom
what's the new value of U the value of U
the value of U at X plus Delta X its u
plus Delta u right that's what Delta U
is it's the change in U when when X gets
replaced by Delta X and the change in V
a new value V is U plus Delta is V Plus
Delta V so this is the new value of U
divided by the new value of V that's
that's the beginning and then I subtract
off the old values which are you - fee
this will be easier to work this out
this when I write it out this way so now
that we'll cross multiply as I said so I
get u v plus Delta u times V minus now
across multiply this way you get u v
minus u times Delta V and I divide all
this by V Plus Delta V times u ok now
the reason I like to do it this way is
that you see the cancellation happening
here u v and u v occur twice and so I
can cancel them and I will and I'll
answer these questions in a minute
whoo that's a V all right oh good
anything else that's what all the hands
were good all right so I cancel these
and what I'm left with in is Delta u
times V minus u times Delta V and all
this is over the plus Delta V times V
okay there's the difference there's the
the change in the quotient the change in
this function is given by this form you
and now to compute the derivative I want
to divide by Delta X and take the limit
so let's write that down Delta u V
divided by Delta X is this formula here
divided by Delta X and again I'm going
to put the Delta X under these Delta U
and Delta V okay I'm going to put Delta
X in the denominator that I can think of
that as dividing into this factor in
this factor so this is Delta u over
Delta x times V minus u times Delta V
over del X and all that is divided by
the same denominator V Plus Delta V
times V right push put the Delta X up in
the numerator there next up take the
limit as Delta X goes to zero I get by
definition the derivative of U divided
by V and on the right hand side well
this is the derivative UD u DX right I'm
V and then u times and here it's the
derivative DV DX now what about the
denominator so when when Delta X goes to
0 V stays the same V stays the same what
happens to this Delta V it goes to 0
again because V is continuous so so
again Delta Delta V goes to 0 with Delta
X because they're continuous and you
just get V times V I think that's the
formula
I wrote down over there the derivative
of U times V minus u times the
derivative of V and all divided by the
square of the old denominator well
that's it that's the quotient rule weird
formula let's see an application let's
see an example
so the example I'm going to give is
pretty simple I'm going to take the
numerator to be just 1 so I'm going to
take you equals 1 so now I'm
differentiating 1 over V the reciprocal
of a function 1 over a function here's
here's a copy of my rule what's 2 u DX
in that case use a constant so that term
is 0 in this rule they don't have to
worry about this I get a minus and then
u U is 1 and DV DX well VG is what every
V is I'll write V DV DX is V Prime and
then I get a V squared in the
denominator so that's the rule - I could
submit as B to the minus 2 V Prime the
minus V prime divided by V squared
that's the derivative of 1 over V how
about it evens even a sub example of
that I'm going to take the special case
where u is equal to 1 again and V is a
power of X and I'm going to use the rule
that we developed earlier about the
derivative of X to the N so what do I
get here D over DX of 1 over X to the N
is I'm plugging into this formula here
with V equals x to the N so I get minus
V to the minus 2 all right if X to the
if V is X to the n V to the minus 2 is
by the rule of exponents X to the minus
2n
and then V prime is the derivative of X
to the N which is n X to the N minus 1
okay so let's put these together there's
several powers of X here I can put them
together I get n times X to the minus
two n plus n minus one one of these ends
cancels and what I'm left with is minus
n minus one so we've computed the
derivative of 1 over X to the N which I
could also write as X to the minus n
right
so I've computed the derivative of
negative powers of X and this is the
formula that I get if you think of this
minus n as a unit as a thing to itself
it occurs here in the exponent it occurs
here and it occurs here so how does that
compare with the formula that we had up
here the derivative of a power of X is
that power times X to one less than that
power that's exactly the same as the
rule that I wrote down here but the
power here is happens to be a negative
number and the same negative number
shows up as a coefficient and there in
the exponent yeah
how did I do this
pour it inside
where did that X to the minus 2n come
from so the rule I'm applying this rule
so the denominator in the quotient rule
is V squared and V was X to the N so the
denominator is X to the 2n and I decided
to write it as X to the minus 2n so so
the Green comments there
what they say is that I can I can
enlarge this rule this exact same rule
happens is true for negative values of n
as well as positive values of n so
there's something new in your list of
rules that you can apply of values of
the derivative that standard rule is
true for negative as well as positive
exponents and that comes out of the
quotient rule okay so we've done two
rules I talked about the the product
rule and the quotient rule what's next
let's do the chain rule so this is a
composition rule
so the kind of thing that I have in mind
composition of functions is about
substitution so the kind of function
that I have in mind is for instance why
is the sine of T raised to the 10th
power that's a new one
haven't seen how to differentiate that
before I think this kind of power of a
trig function happens very often
you've seen them happen as well I'm sure
already and there's a there's a little
notational switch that people use
they'll write sine to the ten of T but
remember that when you write sine to the
ten of T what you mean is take the sine
of T and then take the tenth power of
that that's the meaning of sine to the
tan of T so the method in the method of
dealing with this kind of composition of
functions is to introduce use new
variable names what I mean is I can
think of this sine of T raised to the
tenth power
I can think of it as a two-step process
first of all I compute the sine of T and
let's call a result X there's the new
variable name and then I express Y in
terms of X of so Y says take this and
raise it to the tenth power
in other words Y is the function X to
the tenth power and then you plug x
equals sine of T into that and you get
the formula for what Y is in terms of T
so it's good practice to introduce new
letters when they're convenient and this
is one place where it's very convenient
so let's find a rule for differentiating
a composition a function that can be
expressed by doing one function and then
applying another function and here's the
rule
well maybe I'll actually derive this
rule first and then you'll see what it
is in fact the rule is very simple to
derive so this is a proof first and then
you'll write down the rule I'm
interested in Delta Y over Delta t y is
a function of X X is a function of T and
I'm interested in how Y changes with
respect to T with respect to the
original variable T well because of that
intermediate variable I can write this
as Delta Y divided by Delta x times
Delta X divided by delta T it cancels
right the Delta X cancels the change in
that intermediate variable cancels out
this is just basic algebra but what
happens when I let Delta t get small
well this gives me dy DT and on the
right hand side I get dy DX times DX DT
so students will often remember this
rule this is the rule by saying that you
can cancel out the D X's and that's not
so far from from the truth that's a good
way to think of it in other words this
is the so-called chain rule and it says
that differentiating differentiation
takes of a composition
here's a product it's just the product
of the two derivatives so so that's how
you differentiate a composite of two
functions and let's just do an example
let's do this example see what what that
how that comes out so let's
differentiate what did I say sine of T
raised to the tenth power
okay there's an inside function and an
outside function the inside function is
X as a function of T that is this is the
inside function and this is the outside
function so the rule says first of all
let's differentiate the outside function
take dy DX differentiate it with respect
to that variable X the outside function
is the 10th power what's its derivative
so I get ten X to the ninth power I'm
using in this in this in this just in
this account on using this newly
introduced variable named X so the
derivative of the outside function is
ten X to the ninth and then here's the
inside function and the next thing I
want to do is differentiate it so what's
DX DT D sine T the derivative of sine T
all right that's cosine T that's what
the chain rule gives you this is correct
but it might but since we were the ones
to introduce this notation X here that
wasn't given to us in the original
problem here the last step in this
process should be to put back to
substitute back in what X is in terms of
T
so X was sine of T was sine of T so that
tells me that I get I get ten times sine
of T raised to the ninth power that's X
to the ninth times the cosine of T or
what's the same thing sine to the ninth
of T cosine of T so there's an
application of the chain rule you know
people I thought people often wonder
where the name chain rule comes from I
was just wondering about that myself
so is it because is because it chains
you down there's a chain so because it
chains you down I thought is it
like a chain fence I think I've decided
what it is it's because by using it you
burst the chains of differentiation and
you can differentiate many more
functions using it so then you want to
think of the chain rule just think about
changing it lets you burst free
let me give you another application of
the chain rule
ready for this one so I'd like to
differentiate the sign of 10t now okay
so what's this is again it's a composite
of two functions what's the inside
function okay so I think I'll introduce
this new notation X is 10 T and the
outside function is the sign so Y is the
sum of X so now the chain rule says dy
DT is okay let's see I take the
derivative of the outside function and
what's that sign Prime we can put
substitute what we know what sign prime
is so I get cosine of whatever X and
then x is what now I differentiate the
inside function which is just 10 so I
could write this as 10 cosine of what 10
T X is 10 T now once you get used to
this this middle variable you don't have
to give a name for it you can just think
about it in your mind without actually
writing it down dy D D D of sine of 10 T
I'll just do it again without
introducing this middle variable
explicitly think about it I first of all
differentiate the outside function and I
get cosine but I don't change the thing
that I'm plugging into it it's still X
that I'm plugging into it X is 10 T so
let's just write 10 T and not worry
about that name of that extra variable
if it confuses you introduce the new
variable and do it carefully and slowly
like this but quite quickly I think
you'll get to be able to keep that step
in your mind I'm not quite done yet I
haven't differentiated the inside
function the derivative of 10 T is 10 so
you get again the same result a little
shortcut that you'll get used to really
and truly once you have the chain rule
the world is yours to conquer its puts
you in a very very powerful position ok
well let's see what have I covered today
I've talked about product rule quotient
rule composition I should tell you
something about higher derivatives as
well so let's do that this is a simple
story higher is a kind of a strange word
it just means differentiate over and
over again
all right so let's see if we have a
function U or U of X please allow me to
just write it as briefly as you well I
can this is a sort of notational thing I
can differentiate it I get u Prime
that's the derivative that's a new
function like if you started with a sign
that's going to be the cosine a new
function so I can differentiate it again
and the notation for the differentiating
it again is U prime prime so u prime
prime is just u prime differentiate it
again for example if u is the sign of of
X so u prime is the cosine of X has
professor jerison talked about what the
derivative of cosine is what is it ha
okay
so u prime prime is minus because minus
the sine of X let me go on what do you
suppose U prime prime needs I guess it's
the derivative of u prime prime it's
called the third derivative and u prime
prime is called the second derivative
and it's u prime crime differentiate it
again so to compute u prime prime prime
in this example what do I do I
differentiate that again there's a
constant term minus one constant factor
that comes out the derivative a sign is
what okay so the new prime prime is
minus the cosine of X let's do it again
now after a while you get tired of
writing these things and so maybe I'll
use the notation u upper four that's the
fourth derivative that's u prime prime
prime prime or it's u prime prime prime
differentiate it again fourth derivative
and what is that in this example
okay the cosine is has derivative minus
the sine like you told me and that minus
sign cancels with that sign and
altogether I get plus the sine of X
that's pretty bizarre when I
differentiate the function sine of X for
x I get back to the sine of X again
that's the way it is now this notation
prime prime prime prime and things like
that there are different ways of there
are different different variants of that
notation other notation for example as
another notation
well you've used the notation to udx
before you prime also could be not
denoted d u DX i think we've already
here today use this way of rewriting vu
DX I think when I was talking about DDT
of UV and so on I pulled that D divided
by DT outside and put whatever function
you're differentiating over to the right
so that's just a notational switch it
looks good it looks like good algebra
doesn't it as a further but what it's
doing is regarding this notation as an
operator it's something that you apply
to a function to get a new function I
apply it to the sine function and I get
the cosine function I apply it to x
squared and I get to X this thing here
that symbol represents an operator which
you apply to be applied to a function
and the operator says take the function
and differentiate it so further notation
that people often use is they give a
different name to that operator
they'll write capital D for it so this
is just using capital D for the symbol D
DX
so in terms of that notation let's see
let's write down what higher derivatives
look like
so let's see that's what you prime is
how about you prime prime let's write
that in terms of the d/dx notation well
I'm supposed to differentiate u Prime
right so that's d D D DX applied to the
function D u DX differentiate the
derivative that's what I've done or I
could write that as DDX applied to DDX
supplied to you just pulling that you
outside so I'm doing DDX twice I'm doing
that operator twice I could write that
as DDX quantity squared applied to you
differentiate twice and do it to the
function U or I could write it as now
this is this is a strange one I could
also write this I guess says like that
it's getting stranger and stranger isn't
it this is definitely just a kind of
abuse of notation but and then and then
people will go even further and write d
squared u divided by DX squared so this
is the strangest one this identity
quality is the strangest one because you
may think that you're taking D of the
quantity x squared but that's not what's
intended this is not d of x squared
what's intended is the quantity DX
squared in this notation which is very
common what's intended by the
denominator is the quantity DX squared
it's part of the second differentiation
operator so I've written a bunch of
equalities down here and there's the
only content to them is that these are
all different notations for the same
thing very you'll see this notation very
commonly and so for instance the third
derivative is d cubed u divided by DX
cubed and so on sorry something's hot
yes absolutely or an equally good
notation is to write the operator
capital D done three times to you
absolutely so I guess I should also
write over here when I was talking about
D squared the second derivative another
what another notation is do the operator
capital D twice let's see an example of
how this can be applied I'll answer this
question
yeah so the question is whether the
fourth derivative always gives you the
original function back like what
happened here no that's very very
special to sines and cosines right and
in fact let's see an example of that
I'll do the I'll do a calculation let's
calculate the IMP derivative of X to the
n ok n is a number like 1 2 3 4 so here
we go let's do this so let's do this bit
by bit what's the first derivative of X
to the N so everybody knows this I'm
just using a new notation this capital D
notation so it's n X to the N minus 1
and now you know by the way n could be a
negative number for that but for now for
this this application I want to take n
to be 1 2 3 and so on one of those
numbers okay we did 1 derivative let's
do compute the second derivative of X to
the N well there's this n constant that
comes out and then the exponent comes
down and it gets reduced by 1 right
shall I do one more d cubed x to the N
is n times n minus 1 that's the constant
from here times that exponent n minus 2
times 1 less n minus 3 it's the new
exponent well I keep on going until I
come to a different blackboard
now I think I'm going to stop when I get
to the N minus first derivative so we
can see what's what's likely to happen
so when I took the third derivative
I had the N minus third power of X and
when I took the second derivative I had
the second power of X so I think in
jannat what will happen when I have the
N minus first derivative is I'll have
the first power of X left over the
powers of X keep coming down and what
I've done at n minus 1 times I get the
first power and then I get a big
constant out in front here times more
and more and more of these smaller and
smaller integers that come down what's
the last integer that came down before I
got it when I got X to the first here
well well let's see it's just 2 because
this X to the first power occurred as
the derivative of x squared and the
coefficient of that is in front of that
is 2 so that's what you get the numbers
n n minus 1 and so on down to 2 times X
to the first 2 now we can differentiate
one more time and calculate what this is
X to the N and calculate what d NX to
the N is so I get the same number n
times n minus 1 and so on and so on
times 2 and then I guess I'll say times
1 times what's the derivative of X to
the 1 1 so x 1 if you like time 1 times
1 where this 1 means the constant
function 1 does anyone know what this
number is called that's has a name it's
called in factorial and it's written in
exclamation point and we've just used an
example of mathematical induction
so the end result is DN X to the N is n
factorial constant okay that's that's a
neat fact final question for the lecture
is what's D to the N plus 1
applied to X to the N ha excellent it's
the derivative of a constant so at 0
okay thank you